[Music]  we'll be a big success you got to go to  the premiere okay and I saw this a  photograph of you is this you with JWoww  what's going on in this paragraph yeah  you really did bring the sound effect  yeah I'm actually pointing to the things  that actually made her famous I couldn't  believe that this is the reason why she  was famous and she lets you do that you  actually just point out her breath yes  she's a very very cool person you know  she's there you watch the show Jersey  Shore I don't know Wow nothing no people  here like she was there with her  boyfriend Roger and they're just both  like walking amazing bodies and  everybody's thinking is just like wow to  watch those two have sex when it would  be probably amazing that's what  everyone's thinking yeah I actually  spoke to everyone